[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN MATSUMOTO: Cloud
Bigtable is a NoSQL database
that has the scale,
speed, and reliability
necessary to handle
big data workloads.
In previous episodes,
we learned about some
of Bigtable's key features,
as well as its data model.
We also took a look
at how Bigtable
is being used in a diverse
group of industries,
like retail, transportation
and fraud detection.
In this episode, we're
going to learn more about
how Bigtable can be used for a
key use case, personalization.
Across industries,
data is helping
businesses elevate the customer
experience to new heights.
One particular area
where data is helping
is personalization, delivering
a tailored experience
to each customer based
on their own unique needs
and preferences.
Personalization
is all around us.
If you're an online
shopper, you might
notice the product
recommendations that pop up
based on your purchase history.
If you use a video
streaming service,
you'll probably
get recommendations
for new movies and TV
shows based on what
you've watched in the past.
And if you like music, your
digital music service probably
uses personalization to
help you discover new songs
and playlists.
Data is at the heart
of personalization,
but this presents
unique challenges
to businesses trying
to harness it.
Luckily, Bigtable is great
for supporting personalization
at scale because of its unique
combination of scale, speed,
and reliability.
Personalization requires
businesses to store and access
large volumes of data.
Bigtable is a highly
scalable database,
allowing you to store
up to petabytes of data.
In fact, Bigtable
supports trillions of rows
with millions of columns.
And each row in
Bigtable supports up
to 256 megabytes of
data, so you can easily
store all personalization data
for an individual customer
in a single row.
Bigtable databases can be
scaled linearly at zero downtime
by adding or removing
nodes, each of which
provides up to 10,000
additional queries per second
and is attached to
additional storage capacity.
Personalization also
requires a database
that can quickly write large
volumes of data concurrently
for many users, since
customer behavior needs
to be continually captured to
inform future recommendations.
Bigtable meets this
challenge with the ability
to handle millions of read
and write requests per second.
And it's able to do
so at low latency,
on the order of
single-digit milliseconds.
This is critical
for personalization,
since you wouldn't
want users to have
to wait around for
personalized recommendations.
Bigtable's flexible
NoSQL data model also
works well for personalization.
Traditional relational
databases assume a fixed schema
that will change
infrequently over time.
But NoSQL databases relax
the rigidity of the schema
and allow for data structures
to evolve much more
easily over time.
Another important aspect
of the Bigtable data model
is that its tables are sparse,
meaning that if a column is not
built in for a given row, you
don't pay for that empty cell.
In an e-commerce
example, you might
have a row for each customer
and a column for each product
that they may have engaged with.
With Bigtable's
NoSQL data model,
it's easy to add new
columns to the table
as new products are introduced.
And if a customer hasn't
engaged with a given product,
that cell will be
empty, and you don't
end up paying for its space,
because Bigtable tables are
sparse.
Of course, storing
customer information
is only one step to performing
personalization at scale.
The next step is finding
ways to make that data useful
using machine learning and
big data analysis tools.
Bigtable has you covered
with easy integration
with Google Tools like
BigQuery, TensorFlow, Dataproc,
and Dataflow, as well as Apache
tools like HBase, Hadoop, Beam,
and Spark.
We've covered just a
few of the key reasons
why Bigtable is great
for personalization.
But other reasons include
low Total Cost of Ownership,
or TCO, for high
throughput workloads;
consistent performance around
the world because of data
replication across Google
data centers internationally;
and business-critical
reliability,
with up to 99.999%
availability SLA.
Let's take a look at an example
of how Bigtable tables could
be used for an e-commerce
website looking to recommend
products to users based on their
viewing and purchase history.
First, we might have
a user history table.
This table stores information
about user sessions,
including which
products they view,
add to their cart, and purchase.
Next, we could have a user
personalization table.
This table stores
recommended products
for each user, which would be
generated dynamically over time
using machine learning.
It can also store users' own
stated preferences from a wish
list of saved items.
And finally, we might have a
product recommendation table.
This would provide
product recommendations
based on an original product.
For example, if a customer
bought a blue t-shirt,
we might recommend them
other types of blue t-shirts.
So there you have
it, an overview
of how Bigtable's speed,
scalability, and reliability
makes it great for
personalization use cases.
If you're curious to learn
more, follow the links
below for more information.
Thanks for joining
us today and stay
tuned for more episodes
about Bigtable.